non
[Musique]
aujourd'hui départ pour las vegas
j'ai un avion dans trois heures vous pas
tardé le temps de se préparer et on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment y aller
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec un bon match
on est à l'aéroport de laguardia j'ai un
vol qui fait new york cincinnati
cincinnati las vegas 2h30 ce premier vol
4h30 sur l'autre si l'on comprend
décalage est vraiment bousculer un peu
fatiguant quand même mais bon rien aux
films de quoi boire et ben oui comme ça
[Musique]
cincinnati là j'ai une pause avant de
repartir à las vegas là j'ai bossé sur
ma prochaine vidéo et on part
directement à vegas d'ici deux ans
[Musique]
enfin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en deux
avaaz dgac travers des rues c'est
impossible
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est en
direct de las vegas pour le crs je suis
arrivé hier alors une journée un petit
peu galère c'était un peu la journée de
l'embarras avec un airbnb qui n'a pas de
connexion internet donc c'était vraiment
la galère pour trouver du web c'est beau
j'ai trouvé un bureau dans un diner ils
ont une connexion wifi qui va super vite
alors ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui et
pour tous les jours sur le crs on va
faire une vidéo développe par jour où je
vais vous montrer vraiment les grandes
tendances ce que j'ai vu les produits du
moment
les produits que j'ai vu sur la journée
et ce que je ferais je vous sortir est
tous les jours une vidéo produit une
vidéo test à chaque fois pour chaque
vidéo
donc chaque fois que je verrai un
produit qui me semblera intéressant je
vous ferai une vidéo complète je pourrai
pas tout sortir cette semaine parce
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à voir donc j'en sortirai au fur
et à mesure donc rester connecté abonnez
vous et on commence tout de suite cette
session du cs 2018
[Musique]
pas
un truc est juste énorme
il ya de la contrepartie il ya le stand
lg arrière on va aller faire un tour
il ya bien sûr aussi l'automobile avec
ford juste là
[Musique]
60 des contenus super impressionnant
bon
je
[Musique]
lg un stand qui est vraiment très
impressionnant avec plein de nouveaux
écrans oled
il ya de la cad kyle à 8 heures hier du
dol division il ya énormément de belles
images ont les mêmes sur des écrans
deviennent des oeuvres d'art
[Musique]
là juste derrière moi vous avez les
nouveaux propos alger
des assistants pour vous aider dans vos
courses de porter vos bagages porter vos
valises vraiment faire du confort de vie
pour se faire aider davantage par les
machines
et c'est en ça que contre aimons nous
aider ces robots
[Musique]
là derrière on est une présentation de
google assistant qui est intégrée à la
télé elle gît avec la commande piloter
tout ce que vous voulez ce fait est que
ce soit activé la clim changer la
couleur la lumière joue à la xbox
regarder youtube regarder vos photos
votre agenda votre météo tout ce qu'on
peut faire avec google assistante
pouvait faire désormais sur le psg ça
c'est vrai que c'est quand même super
pratique
[Musique]
j'avais porté toujours à l'honneur chez
lg cette fois ci à la différence de
lifar où on avait uniquement enfin
uniquement pas vraiment lu lgv trompe de
présenter
trouver mon casque réalité virtuelle je
vais essayer ça
[Musique]
derrière cette énorme car hélas jusqu'au
fond se trouve le stand de samsung un
stand requis à d'être énorme je suis pas
encore allé on va les voir ensemble et à
mon avis on n'est pas au bout de nos
surprises
[Musique]
un écran qui campait astra briquet par
samsung
[Musique]
ces jeux
magnifique alors utilisation prendra
marché soit globalement pas grand chose
à moins d'avoir château je ne sais quoi
mais c'est vraiment super impressionnant
voir ce que cinq films capables de faire
avec cet écran
[Musique]
oh
là on a le stand sony comme vous le
voyez petit stand
comme d'habitude c'est énorme on va le
voir parce qu'a priori il ya des
nouveaux produits sains et chez sony et
je pense qu'on va pas être déçu
[Musique]
là on est sur le stand de voyous et
houaïlou et c'est aussi au nord je vais
vous faire de vidéos sur les honore view
10la et plus sur le honore ses tics sont
restés connectés abonnez-vous parce que
on va en parler très très prochainement
[Musique]
derrière moi vous avez le stand de
qualcomm paul comme c'est effectivement
le fabricant des processeurs snapdragon
qui équipe et énormément de modèles de
smartphones son marché regardez moi ce
stand de fou pour intel
je compte bien continuer le stand est
juste énorme
[Musique]
là on est sur le stand de zte alors et
je sais pas si vous connaissez un
fabricant de smartphones et de plomb
très intéressante
et justement ils ont
[Musique]
l'axone m qui a l'air en tout cas de
ressembler à ce que pourrait être un
écran pliable
c'est derrière moi
le stand dj axe à très grand stand bien
évidemment vous connaissez des jets chez
pause ils ont les ossements os mobile os
non plus le smo ronin pour la gamme
plutôt professionnelle mavic malik
profane 334 enfin tout ce qui concerne
la stabilisation son sort d'une rose ou
sur du bingo lé dj hi à la pointe
on va aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil
parce qu'à mon avis ce qui est nouveau
[Musique]
regardez-moi seconde comment il est non
vous regardez un truc hyper flippant
là j'ai été scannés par big brother vous
allez voir c'est une caméra dit que vous
passiez reconnais votre visage et elle
est capable de savoir qui vous êtes ltd
photo de vous en temps réel c'est
vraiment flippant ça c'est vraiment
minority report une version picasa fonds
venant coter robotique on va vraiment ce
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec la
robotique que ce soit de la sécurisation
c'est à dire être capable de repérer les
personnes de les reconnaître être aussi
bien capable de sécuriser des villes
notamment pour la problématique de
service public
on va pouvoir retrouver derrière il ya
tout tout c'est une option qu'ils soient
représentés la noria des choses qui te
paraissent assez rassurant d'autres qui
sont complètement flippante
mais bon on n'arrête pas le progrès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et le rêve est devenu réalité grâce à
atari des jeux auxquels je jouais
j'étais gamin on les a en vrai avec
l'atari pong c'est qui l'eût cru j'en ai
rêvé pendant des années
[Musique]
ce truc est complètement fou pour tous
les amateurs ping pong au port
s'entraîner tout seul et après champion
du monde juste dingue
côté drôle ni aussi énormément de
produits alors vous avez plein de
marques connues il ya dj a effectivement
quand on connaît le mieux
il ya aussi plein d'autres moins bons là
là ya pas de démo pour moi j'en ai l'air
il ya aussi plein d'autres drones voilà
ici si vous avez le teckel c'est plus dû
jouer ça mais bon du rhône aussi
l'arrière ici et là derrière moi vous
avez des mastodontes regarder ça c'est
drôle là c'est énorme
[Musique]
le csc aussi des rencontres là on est
avec by justin
je suis un très grand fan de justin my
way or même justin lin yu qingtai
razer désolé accent français bien
évidemment c'est tout l'univers du gamer
et il a senti n'ya pas longtemps
le razer phone je n'ai pas encore essayé
je vais aller voir si l'on parce qu'à
mon avis est un produit ça aussi puisque
depuis un déchirer pour tous les joueurs
nintendo est dans la place aussi avec un
stand nintendo switch
[Musique]
bon c'est vrai que vous avez aussi
beaucoup de baseball de stabilisateur
pour un appareil photo pour une gaufre
on sait vraiment ce qui est en vogue
parce que ça permet vraiment de films et
d'avoir une image qui complètement
stabilisée naturellement comme un
steadicam et pas d'avoir une
stabilisation sur cinq axes qu'on risque
d'avoir moins touché avec avec le gh5
donc ça on en retrouve énormément il y a
bien évidemment dj hi avec son os mobile
sur lequel vous pouvez poser un petit
smartphone les des solutions comme celle
de sion
filles
il y en a beaucoup et c'est vraiment
super intéressant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la chose se rendra pas compte
directement l'image mais la télé quand
on le regarde on prend des lunettes en
3d sur les yeux l'image se détache
vraiment c'est très très étrange parce
que on regarde un écran et pourtant on a
de la 3d dès qu'on bouge c'est hyper
particulier mais c'est vraiment un truc
de fou voilà ce que pour cette première
journée de ce s on va revenir demain on
va revenir après demain après apprennent
aux enfants ont fait le seul sens
complet on va en voir des choses donc
restez connectés bien évidemment aux
invite à vous abonner mais pour
l'instant ne partez pas encore le
journal n'est pas terminée je dirais pas
qu'elle fait que commencer mais presque
encore des surprises
[Musique]
ce club là ok donc mai
tiny de blogs mckeown c'est possible
[Musique]
c'est pas encore fini la journée pas
terminer cette ville est complètement
folle maintenant on est le premier soir
du cs qu'est-ce qu'on fait le premier
sort du cs je le met dans le mille
eh bien on va la soirée des exposants
organisé dans la discothèque du césar
palace
alors j'espère qu'ils vont baisser
rentrée que ma caméra sinon j'ai mon
iphone on va perdre en qualité
mais reconnaît pas les trucs de dingue
cette ville est complètement démente
c'est à dire que qui pleuve qu'il vente
qu'il neige neige je suis pas sûr il y à
de la musique partout ce matin 7 et
glock qu'il était quelque chose comme 7h
7h30 du matin pleuvait des trombes d'eau
et avait pourtant de la musique laisse
dans la rue avec les anciens qui joue et
c'est hallucinant sinon bon ça
ça a son charme
j'ai pas su revenir ici en vacances ce
qui est difficile c'est que tout est
optimisé pour faire de l'oseille
tu vois vraiment que y'a pas un coin de
rue qui n'est pas optimisé pour venir
prendre ton pognon bon apprêtez à las
vegas
t'es au courant n'arrive pas de nulle
part non plus et comment ça marche
mais bon ça a son charme est juste la
somme
[Musique]
donc là je suis juste devant le caesar
palace je vais tenter de rentrer que ma
caméra
c'est pas gagné mais on va voir si ça
marche
en tout cas je pense que ça va être une
grosse soir
[Musique]
quoi